un juicio de 18 meses realizado en
secreto solo una imagen de
Data de mayo 2021 ha sido publicada
desde que se convirtió en prisionera de
la junta tras su golpe de estado este
icono de la Democracia fue durante mucho
tiempo consejera de estado y líder de
facto de myanmar durante 5 años cuando
los militares que habían perdido las
elecciones derrocaron al gobierno
elegido democráticamente en febrero de
2021 desde el golpe y su detención un
tribunal militar atrasado el destino de
la Premio Nobel de paz con una serie de
acusaciones y sentencias por corrupción
en el último caso el tribunal la condenó
a siete años más de detención por el uso
indebido de un helicóptero así el total
de condenas suman 33 años de prisión sin
embargo la conclusión del juicio permite
albergar la esperanza de que el
activista de 77 años pueda recibir
pronto visitas suchi ha calificado de
absurdos los cargos que le imputan
la comunidad internacional también los
considera una farsa destinada a reforzar
El poder del ejército el consejo de
seguridad de la ONU en una inusual
unanimidad pidió la semana pasada la
junta que liberara Sushi y a todos los
presos detenidos arbitrariamente desde
el golpe los militares han conseguido
sofocar un amplio movimiento pero
democrático con medidas represivas pero
una guerrilla ciudadana sigue
contraatacando con intentos de hacer
Mella en la mano de hierro de los
militares